So the point being, you were right, Bryce. I was wrong. I'm going to need a clip of that little part of the conversation. What the? You were right. I was wrong? Yes. I'll put that as the cold open.
所以重点是，你是对的，Bryce。我错了。我需要那段对话的一小段剪辑。什么？你是对的。我错了？是的。我会把它作为开场白。
How about that? So episode 165, you'll be able to go back to at any point you want. Perfect. Welcome to ADSP, the podcast episode 165 recorded on January 18th, 2024. My name is Connor and today with my co-host Bryce, we look back at some of the highlights of the year 2023 in our annual retro LLMs, Rust versus C++, and we also look ahead to the year 2023 in our annual retro, LLM's Rust vs. C++, and we also look ahead to the year 2024. I did call you with the intention of start early, end early. So let's get this going.
怎么样？所以第165集，你随时都可以回头听。完美。欢迎来到ADSP，这是2024年1月18日录制的第165集播客。我是Connor，今天和我的联合主持人Bryce一起，回顾我们年度回顾中的2023年亮点，包括LLM、Rust与C++，我们还将展望2024年。我给你打电话是想早点开始，早点结束。所以让我们开始吧。
All right, 424, folks. We're going to timebox this to 30 minutes, so we will be done five minutes before the hour. Welcome to Happy New Year. Because I'm not actually even sure. You so quickly were eager to ask me your credit card number question last time. I don't think we exchanged any pleasantries, any Happy New Years. Happy New Year.
好了，424，各位。我们要把时间限制在30分钟内，所以我们会在整点前五分钟结束。欢迎，新年快乐。因为我甚至不确定。你上次那么急着问我信用卡号码的问题。我想我们没交换任何客套话，没说新年快乐。新年快乐。
Happy New Year. I mean, we did chat a little bit afterwards. But anyways, none of that made it because I mentioned on the last edit of episode 164, Microsoft screwed us two different ways. A bit of it's my fault. I think I actually do have Audacity set up to back things up. I went and checked it, but it did not back things up when the computer restarted. I was just reading a thread about that, about Audacity not backing things up when Windows does forced updates because I was trying to figure out how to prevent it from happening to me.
新年快乐。我的意思是，我们之后确实聊了一会儿。但无论如何，这些都没录进去，因为我在第164集的最后一次编辑中提到，微软以两种不同的方式坑了我们。有一部分是我的错。我想我确实把Audacity设置成了自动备份。我去检查了，但电脑重启时它并没有备份。我刚读到一篇关于这个的帖子，说Windows强制更新时Audacity不会备份，因为我当时正试图弄清楚如何防止这种情况发生在我身上。
Yeah. And the thing is, like 75% of the time when that has happened, it's only happened a handful of times, my recordings are recovered. So they typically are recovered. But in this one case, I had three different Audacity projects. Technically, one of them was outtakes from our conversation with Sean, where we were talking about an individual in the C++ community having gone to a new employer, and we had to cut all that out. And I was going to insert it in one of these episodes at some point, but I'll have to go back and find that if we're going to do that. Anyways, point is, Microsoft, Windows restarted, then Teams crashed. We're still using Teams. Why are we still using Teams, Bryce? It's a good question.
是的。问题是，75%的情况下，这种情况发生时——虽然只发生过几次——我的录音都能恢复。所以它们通常是可以恢复的。但在这次案例中，我有三个不同的Audacity项目。严格来说，其中一个是我们在与Sean对话时的花絮，当时我们谈到C++社区的一个人去了新雇主那里，我们不得不把那部分全部剪掉。我本来打算在某个时候把它插入到这些剧集中，但如果我们要这样做，我得回去找找。无论如何，重点是，微软，Windows重启了，然后Teams崩溃了。我们还在用Teams。为什么我们还在用Teams，Bryce？这是个好问题。
Because we're cheap and we don't have another alternative. Look, you know the reason that we use Zoom? Because at the time, I was an officer of an ISO committee. And so I had a Zoom account paid for by ISO. And so I just used that for everything. But now I don't have any paid Zoom account. So we're limited to an hour or 40 minutes or something when we have more than two people. And so, yeah, we're cheap.
因为我们很穷，没有其他选择。听着，你知道我们用Zoom的原因吗？因为当时我是ISO委员会的官员。所以我有一个由ISO支付的Zoom账户。所以我什么都用它。但现在我没有任何付费的Zoom账户。所以当有超过两个人时，我们被限制在1小时或40分钟内。所以，是的，我们很穷。
Now we're using Teams because that's what NVIDIA uses. And so once again, we're cheap. I'm cheap at least. Yeah, I agree. I mean, we at some point, we're going to get merch. 2024 is the year of merch. I will have stickers by the time I'm going to conferences. Here's a quick question though.
现在我们用Teams是因为NVIDIA在用。所以再一次，我们很穷。至少我很穷。是的，我同意。我的意思是，我们迟早会做周边产品。2024年是周边产品之年。等我去参加会议时，我会有贴纸。不过这里有个简单的问题。
Take your mic. The reason I bring this up is because I mentioned this at the top of episode 164. This was an edit that I added in. So Bryce did not hear this. But I recently came across my new favorite podcast called acquired, also known as acquired FM. And I saw you tweet about, they did four different episodes, three specifically on Nvidia. And then they did an interview with Jensen.
拿着你的麦克风。我提起这个是因为我在第164集的开头提到了这一点。这是我添加的一个编辑。所以Bryce没听到这个。但我最近偶然发现了我也最喜欢的播客，叫Acquired，也叫Acquired FM。我看到你发推文说，他们做了四集不同的节目，其中三集专门讲Nvidia。然后他们还采访了Jensen。
It is amazing folks. I already plugged it once, even if you don't like podcasts, which now that I'm saying that out loud, you're clearly listening to ours. So you must have at least some familiarity with them or desire to listen to them. It's so good. And the reason I bring it up is not to plug it again, but their research and their auto quality and their production value is just so good. It makes me sad about my podcast.
各位，这太棒了。我已经推荐过一次了，即使你不喜欢播客，既然我现在大声说出来，你显然正在听我们的节目。所以你一定对它们至少有一些熟悉或有听它们的欲望。它太好了。我提起它不是为了再次推荐，而是因为他们的研究、音频质量和制作价值太好了。这让我对我的播客感到难过。
Because my audio is good, but Bryce's, you know, Bryce's all over the place. But hey, hey, hey hey we did now i got this thing it's good it's pretty good now but that's why i was asking because it did sound a little tinny but anyways we're doing our best here folks and long-term goals this podcast is going to be going on for decades we are going to we're going to find you know the first class world class experience we're still we're not going to take ourselves as seriously as Acquired takes themselves because I will, and this is a great way to transition. I have misunderstood the value or what the purpose of our podcast is. I love the motto, chaos with sprinkles of information. However, I thought it was a little bit too chaotic last episode, a little too chaotic.
因为我的音频很好，但Bryce的，你知道，Bryce的到处都是问题。但嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，我现在有这个东西了，它很好，现在相当不错，但这就是我问的原因，因为它听起来确实有点刺耳，但无论如何，我们在这里尽力了，各位，长期目标是这个播客将持续几十年，我们将找到，你知道，一流的体验，我们仍然不会像Acquired那样认真对待自己，因为我会，这是一个很好的过渡方式。我误解了我们播客的价值或目的。我喜欢这个座右铭，混乱中撒点信息。然而，我觉得上一集太混乱了，有点太混乱了。
And I asked for feedback. I asked the listeners, please go to Twitter or to GitHub. And we got an overwhelming amount of feedback, 10 different people, eight different comments. And I will stand corrected. Bryce was overwhelmingly correct. I thought it was our worst episode ever. I will read from a few of the comments that were left on the GitHub discussion from Pascal754. Actually, let's see if I click on the profile, do I get a full name? I do not. Although they say they're from South Korea. So shout out to our South Korean listeners. This episode was hilarious. And then they linked to a problem from a Harvard course. If we scroll down a little bit more, I'm not going to read them all. Kent F, let's double click on their profile.
我征求了反馈。我请听众去Twitter或GitHub。我们得到了压倒性的反馈，10个不同的人，8条评论。我收回前言。Bryce是完全正确的。我以为那是我们有史以来最糟糕的一集。我将读几条留在GitHub讨论区上的评论，来自Pascal754。实际上，让我们看看如果我点击个人资料，能看到全名吗？看不到。虽然他们说他们来自韩国。所以向我们的韩国听众致敬。这一集太搞笑了。然后他们链接了一个哈佛课程的问题。如果我们再往下滚动一点，我就不全读了。Kent F，让我们双击他们的个人资料。
This person is located in Oslo, according to GitHub. Could be right, could be wrong. Kent F. So Kent says, Connor, sadly, I have to agree with Bryce. This episode was gold. As they say about streaming services
根据GitHub，这个人位于奥斯陆。可能是对的，也可能是错的。Kent F。所以Kent说，Connor，遗憾的是，我不得不同意Bryce。这一集是金子。正如他们所说的关于流媒体服务
slash cable TV, come for the movies, stay for the TV shows. Your podcast is come for the algorithm stay for the banter a discussion with Sean parent episodes are always platinum grade content thanks the next one says from pet Hill where's pet Hill tuning in from no information but the full name is Peter Hilgenfeld and they mentioned this was fun the high-pitched forwarding noise really really hurts my ears. Please stop it.
斜杠有线电视，为了电影而来，为电视节目留下。你们的播客是为算法而来，为闲聊留下。与Sean Parent的讨论集总是白金级的。谢谢。下一条来自pet Hill，pet Hill是从哪里收听的？没有信息，但全名是Peter Hilgenfeld，他们提到这很有趣，高音的快进噪音真的很伤耳朵。请停止它。
And I have to apologize because I usually only 10x Bryce, but when we went from minute 4 to minute 17 where my audio was still back online, I had to, I think it was 50x it and that really made, it really went high squeaky at that point. We've got another one from ProfRS. ProfRS
我必须道歉，因为我通常只对Bryce进行10倍速处理，但当我们从第4分钟到第17分钟，我的音频还在恢复中时，我不得不，我想是50倍速处理了它，这确实让它在那一点变得非常尖锐刺耳。我们还有一条来自ProfRS的评论。ProfRS
is tuning in from this is Robert I'm going to mispronounce this Skabbrassy I apologize Robert from Valhalla, New York where's Valhalla? Is that close to New York? Do you know where that is?
是从这里收听的，这是Robert，我会读错这个名字，Skabbrassy，我道歉，Robert，来自纽约瓦尔哈拉，瓦尔哈拉在哪里？离纽约近吗？你知道那在哪里吗？
You know all those towns that have names like Valhalla are like real real deep upstate I love how we're just this isn't technically considered doxing, right? If their Simpo is on their GitHub profile, what does mine say? So Valhalla is actually, it's not that far north. It's, I think it's like Westchester County. It's just north of the city.
你知道所有那些名字叫瓦尔哈拉的城镇，就像在州北部很深的地方，我喜欢我们只是，这在技术上不被认为是人肉搜索，对吧？如果他们的Simpo在他们的GitHub个人资料上，我的说什么？所以瓦尔哈拉实际上，它没那么靠北。我想它是在威彻斯特县。就在城市北边。
That definitely sounds right because it looks like they work for, or at least it says next to a little building icon, Westchester Community College. And anyways, yeah, mine says Toronto, Ontario. So I don't think this is doxing. We apologize if people wanted to stay anonymous. But hey, if you're the listener who lives in Valhalla, like, you know, we can get coffee sometimes. We live nearby. But yes, this individual, if I can get back to the comments, said, Bryce, it will definitely be one of my favorite episodes of the year. And to Connor, listenable content wise, it was awful. However, the 90 seconds of 10x audio was outstandingly hilarious.
那听起来绝对正确，因为看起来他们为，或者至少在小建筑图标旁边写着，威彻斯特社区学院工作。无论如何，是的，我的写着安大略省多伦多。所以我不认为这是人肉搜索。如果人们想保持匿名，我们道歉。但嘿，如果你是住在瓦尔哈拉的听众，你知道，我们可以偶尔喝杯咖啡。我们住得很近。但是的，这个人，如果我能回到评论的话，说，Bryce，这绝对会是我今年最喜欢的剧集之一。而对Connor来说，从可听内容来看，它很糟糕。然而，90秒的10倍速音频非常搞笑。
You even 10x'd yourself. I did. Apologize to those whose comments I didn't read. We appreciate all of them. But the point is, overwhelmingly, the listeners gave feedback, and I was wrong. I thought it was a terrible episode. And the listeners, even though maybe they didn't learn a ton, they were clearly entertained. So the point being, you were right, Bryce.
你甚至对自己进行了10倍速处理。我确实做了。向那些我没读到评论的人道歉。我们感谢所有评论。但重点是，压倒性地，听众给出了反馈，我错了。我以为那是糟糕的一集。而听众，即使他们可能没学到太多，他们显然被娱乐了。所以重点是，你是对的，Bryce。
I was wrong. And to get back to Acquired, we're not going to go as professional as them, but we're going to try and give you the best audio quality. I'm going to need a clip of that little part of the conversation. What the? You were right. I was wrong? Yes.
我错了。回到Acquired，我们不会像他们那么专业，但我们会努力给你最好的音频质量。我需要那段对话的一小段剪辑。什么？你是对的。我错了？是的。
I'll put that as the cold open. How about that? So episode 165, you'll be able to go back to at any point you want. Anyways, that's, I think, like almost 10 minutes out of the way. Today's episode is a re-recording of what we already recorded, but Windows destroyed, Microsoft destroyed, and it is the 2023 recap and 2024 look ahead. We've already done this once, so will it be as amazing as it was before? Nobody knows. We're going to throw it over to Bryce, though, first. What were your highlights? Top five, top three. I mean, I already asked you this and you didn't give me a top five, top three.
我会把它作为开场白。怎么样？所以第165集，你随时都可以回头听。无论如何，我想这已经浪费了近10分钟。今天的剧集是我们已经录制过的内容的重录，但Windows毁了它，微软毁了它，这是2023年回顾和2024年展望。我们已经做过一次了，所以它会像以前一样精彩吗？没人知道。不过，我们先把它交给Bryce。你的亮点是什么？前五名，前三名。我的意思是，我已经问过你了，你没给我前五名，前三名。
Will he this time? Will he not? Go ahead, Bryce. Tell us, reflect back on 2023. What stands out to you? So I'm not going to give them any particular order, but I'll say to me, it was the year of large language models, you know, huge theme throughout the tech industry. I think it's going to be a transformative thing that we'll see slow adoption of over the next five to 10 years. So I don't think there'll be as much excitement in the next few years
他这次会吗？他不会吗？继续，Bryce。告诉我们，回顾2023年。什么对你来说最突出？所以我不会给它们任何特定的顺序，但我会说对我来说，这是大型语言模型之年，你知道，整个科技行业的一个巨大主题。我认为这将是一件变革性的事情，我们将在未来5到10年内看到缓慢的采用。所以我认为未来几年不会有那么多兴奋点
because, you know, it's an exciting new technology. But as I always like to say, momentum is king in the software industry. So it takes a long time for things to be adopted. 2023 was also the year of C++23. Great standard. Really proud of the work that we did on that one. Even though I'm no longer chairing on the C++ committee, I'm really proud of the team that I worked with when I was there.
因为，你知道，这是一项令人兴奋的新技术。但正如我常说的，动力在软件行业是王道。所以事情被采用需要很长时间。2023年也是C++23之年。伟大的标准。我真的为我们在那上面所做的工作感到自豪。尽管我不再担任C++委员会的主席，但我为我在那里时共事的团队感到非常自豪。
I had a great time. I think we produced a great standard. This time I get to mention the thing that I left out the last time I did this, which was, of course, a huge highlight for me, was the ADSP Slovenia road trip, which I thought was just a blast. And, you know, we got to do one of these every year. You know, being out on the road, going to visit. It combines my little travels, travel with my love of talking shit about programming languages. And let's see, what other highlights come to mind? I'm trying to think.
我度过了一段美好的时光。我认为我们制定了一个伟大的标准。这次我有机会提到我上次做这个时遗漏的事情，当然，对我来说一个巨大的亮点是ADSP斯洛文尼亚公路旅行，我认为那简直太棒了。而且，你知道，我们每年都得做一次这样的旅行。你知道，在路上，去拜访。它结合了我的小旅行，旅行和我喜欢谈论编程语言坏话的爱好。让我们看看，还有什么亮点浮现在脑海中？我在想。
I think that was mostly everything that you said last time yeah c++ oh yeah i think i i asked you the question so this is the hard thing as i've already asked and have had these answered but the listener hasn't what you know at one point episode 150 probably will go down as our most popular episode of 2023 that was uh is c++ dying but you've kind of flip-flopped when we talked to zach it sounds like reflection is making it now senders and receivers what is your current what is the state of the bryce's opinion on successor languages and c++ even a broken clock is right two times a day um reflection is great i'm super excited about it i really hope it makes it into C++26. I Like set aside that, set aside whether issues
我想那基本上就是你上次说的所有内容，是的，C++，哦，是的，我想我问过你这个问题，所以这是困难的部分，因为我已经问过并得到了这些回答，但听众没有，你知道，第150集可能会成为我们2023年最受欢迎的剧集，那是“C++正在消亡吗”，但当你和Zach交谈时，你有点改变了立场，听起来反射（reflection）现在正在实现，发送者和接收者，你目前对继任语言和C++的看法是什么？即使是坏掉的时钟一天也会准两次，嗯，反射很棒，我非常兴奋，我真的希望它能进入C++26。我喜欢撇开那个，撇开C++有什么问题
there are with C++ and set aside like the question of how good C++ is today. It's a question of acceleration, not velocity. It's a question of where is C++ going and how quickly can it get there? And the evolution process is just simply not sufficient. It's broken in many ways. And without real substantial reform, I think that C++ is a very questionable future. And I've spent a good seven, eight years of my career trying to bring about that reform. And I'm proud of the changes I was able to make, but it's just simply not enough. So I still think that C++ is in trouble. But back to 2023, I think that 2023 is in many ways the year of rust. I think it's really been a year that's been a focal point in rust going from being a challenger to becoming more established and more of a part of the, an incumbent, you know,
撇开C++今天有多好这个问题。这是一个关于加速度的问题，而不是速度。这是一个关于C++要去哪里以及它能多快到达那里的问题？而进化过程根本是不够的。它在许多方面都坏了。如果没有真正的实质性改革，我认为C++的未来是非常值得怀疑的。我花了职业生涯中整整七八年的时间试图推动这种改革。我为我能够做出的改变感到自豪，但这根本不够。所以我仍然认为C++有麻烦了。但回到2023年，我认为2023年在许多方面是Rust之年。我认为这确实是Rust从挑战者变为更成熟、更像是一个现任者的一年，你知道，
it's gone from being the challenger to potentially the challenged. And now we see Rust in the Linux kernel. We're increasingly seeing Rust used in a wide number of projects. Even within my own work, I hear more and more people talking about
它已经从挑战者变成了潜在的被挑战者。现在我们看到Rust在Linux内核中。我们越来越多地看到Rust被用于大量的项目中。即使在我自己的工作中，我也听到越来越多的人谈论
Rust, interested in Rust. I think it's become clear that Rust has succeeded in the space of next generation systems software languages. And I've always said for a long time that to me, almost one of the least interesting things about Rust is the memory safety aspect. And I mean, I think it's a compelling part of it it but that's not what interests me about Rust what interests me about Rust is a systems programming language with a substantially better package management and build ecosystem and a better process and model for evolving the language
Rust，对Rust感兴趣。我认为很明显，Rust在下一代系统软件语言领域已经取得了成功。我一直说，对我来说，Rust最不有趣的事情之一就是内存安全方面。我的意思是，我认为这是它引人注目的部分，但这并不是Rust让我感兴趣的地方，让我感兴趣的是Rust作为一种系统编程语言，拥有实质上更好的包管理和构建生态系统，以及更好的语言进化过程和模型。
now obviously there's been a lot of drama and controversy in the Rust leadership over the past year or two but I do think that that's present in any community and environment. And I am hopeful that those are just growing pains because I think Rust's, at least until recent drama, Rust's community and evolution process has been substantially better than a lot of established languages.
现在显然过去一两年Rust领导层中有很多戏剧性和争议，但我确实认为这在任何社区和环境中都存在。我希望这些只是成长的烦恼，因为我认为Rust的，至少在最近的戏剧之前，Rust的社区和进化过程比许多成熟的语言要好得多。
And I had a lot of hope that it would become a platform for the next generation of systems programming languages and then the next place that we can all build our system software. So any predictions in that space, Rust versus C++ versus other languages over 2024? Do you think it's just going to be more of the same rust on the slow rise and C++ on the slow decline? I think that what we're going to start to see with rust is that we are going to start to see rust experience and overcome various growing pains. You know, I've already heard of some growing pains with cargo and with that ecosystem.
我曾寄予厚望，希望它能成为下一代系统编程语言的平台，然后成为我们所有人都能构建系统软件的下一个地方。那么在这个领域有什么预测吗，2024年Rust与C++与其他语言的对比？你认为这只会是更多同样的情况，Rust缓慢上升，C++缓慢下降吗？我认为我们将开始看到Rust的情况是，我们将开始看到Rust经历并克服各种成长的烦恼。你知道，我已经听说过一些关于Cargo和那个生态系统的成长烦恼。
I'm aware of some other growing pains, but I think that as Rust starts to get more and more up to scale and now that it has to serve a broader and broader set of users, including now kernel developers, and I don't say that as if the kernel, like being in the Linux kernel
我知道还有其他一些成长的烦恼，但我认为随着Rust开始越来越大规模，现在它必须服务于越来越广泛的用户群，包括现在的内核开发者，我这么说并不是因为内核，就像在Linux内核中
is like a game changer thing, but I say that as an example of there's a hundred use cases like the Linux kernel that have very specialized requirements that are now using Rust that weren't using Rust a year ago. And the more and more of those users that have very specialized requirements that Rust adopts, the harder and harder it'll be to make changes and to evolve. And the real test for Rust is, can it maintain its agility and velocity as a language as it builds up a real user base
是一件改变游戏规则的事情，但我说这是作为一个例子，有成百上千个像Linux内核这样有非常特殊要求的用例，现在正在使用Rust，而一年前却没有。Rust采用的那些有非常特殊要求的用户越多，进行更改和进化就越困难。而Rust真正的考验是，当它建立起真正的用户群时，它能否保持作为一种语言的敏捷性和速度
and as it starts to build up a code legacy? You know, Titus Winters loves to say that software engineering is like programming integrated over time or something like that. It's not just about writing code, but it's about how that code is maintained over a long period of time. And those sorts of software engineering challenges, Rust is going to increasingly start to face those. And I do think that this is going to be a year where we will start to see more and more of those growing pains as rust increasingly is adopted in more and more places. It'll be very exciting to see this unfold. I mean, it's already been exciting over the last year, two years, especially with carbon, hylo, circle,
以及当它开始建立代码遗产时？你知道，Titus Winters喜欢说软件工程就像随时间积分的编程之类的。这不仅仅是关于编写代码，而是关于这些代码如何在很长一段时间内被维护。而那些软件工程挑战，Rust将越来越多地开始面对这些。我确实认为这将是我们将开始看到更多这些成长烦恼的一年，因为Rust越来越多地在更多地方被采用。看到这一切展开将非常令人兴奋。我的意思是，过去一两年已经很令人兴奋了，特别是Carbon、Hylo、Circle，
so much going on in space. I do also think that another area where we're going to see a lot of interesting developments in this year is the continued growth of MLIR which is a higher level compiler representation that's part of the LVM project that can be used to build domain specific
在这个领域发生了很多事情。我也确实认为今年我们将看到很多有趣发展的另一个领域是MLIR的持续增长，这是一种更高层次的编译器表示，是LVM项目的一部分，可以用来构建特定领域的
compiler representations and I think that over the next few years we're going to see more and more compilers start to use and adopt MLIR and build all sorts of programming language and domain-specific optimizations and pipelines with MLIR. And I think in many ways, MLIR may democratize compiler technology. So a lot of things that get done today in libraries um or in sort of like bespoke weird quirky code generators or pseudo compilers will start to move more and more to um mlir interesting do you think uh mojo because mojo is being built on top of mlir as well do you think
编译器表示，我认为在未来几年，我们将看到越来越多的编译器开始使用和采用MLIR，并用MLIR构建各种编程语言和特定领域的优化和流水线。我认为在许多方面，MLIR可能会使编译器技术民主化。所以今天在库中完成的许多事情，或者在某种定制的、奇怪的、古怪的代码生成器或伪编译器中完成的事情，将开始越来越多地转向MLIR。有趣，你认为Mojo，因为Mojo也是建立在MLIR之上的，你认为
that'll see any success or you have thoughts there i mean i wouldn't bet against chris latner yeah that's true he he has for those that don't know has had a number of very successful projects including llvm clang swift etc and he is the person behind mojo i i think that it's going to be hard for mojo to succeed though because um it's not at least from what i see it's not a community effort it's very much their thing and the the company behind mojo is if i understand correctly they're a hardware startup more or less yes i actually am not i have not familiarized myself with their business model i've just seen the talks that they've they've pitched hang on i'm looking right now it's uh uh i mean what hardware are they selling um it's the it's the company's called modular i mean even
它会看到任何成功吗，或者你有什么想法？我的意思是，我不会和Chris Lattner对赌。是的，那是真的。他，对于那些不知道的人，已经有许多非常成功的项目，包括LLVM、Clang、Swift等，他是Mojo背后的人。我认为Mojo很难成功，因为嗯，至少从我所看到的，它不是一个社区努力，它非常是他们自己的东西，而且Mojo背后的公司，如果我理解正确的话，他们或多或少是一家硬件初创公司。是的，我实际上没有，我没有熟悉他们的商业模式，我只是看了他们推销的演讲。等等，我正在看，它是，嗯，我的意思是他们卖什么硬件？嗯，这家公司叫Modular。我的意思是甚至
wikipedia call not that's that's rough wikipedia calls it a proprietary programming language even if it is that's a little bit rough to have that be your first line on um uh on uh on wikipedia um uh modular i think they do like ai infrastructure and platform i don't know if they have hardware but i for some reason i thought that they did um uh maybe it's maybe it's hardware agnostic, but it is still, it's not designed as a, at least my impression is that it's not an open thing where they're inviting other contributors and other companies to participate in the development of it yet.
维基百科称，不，那太粗糙了。维基百科称它为专有编程语言，即使它是，作为你的第一行，那也有点粗糙，嗯，嗯，在维基百科上，嗯，嗯，Modular，我想他们做的是人工智能基础设施和平台，我不知道他们是否有硬件，但我出于某种原因认为他们有，嗯，嗯，也许它是，也许它是硬件无关的，但它仍然，它不是被设计为，至少我的印象是它不是一个开放的东西，他们还没有邀请其他贡献者和其他公司参与它的开发。
And I think until that happens, it looks like they don't make their own hardware, but that it's just like an AI platform thingy. I think almost all languages have to go through this test of where they need to see whether they can gain broader adoption than just their one initial champion. If it's just one person, then it looks like they may not have enough steam behind them. And if it's just one company, then people are always going to be worried about like, oh, is this just their company, this one company's thing? Like, oh, is this just Google's language or Facebook's language?
我认为在那发生之前，看起来他们不制造自己的硬件，但它只是像一个人工智能平台之类的东西。我认为几乎所有的语言都必须经历这个考验，看看它们是否能获得比仅仅是它们最初的一个拥护者更广泛的采用。如果只有一个人，那么看起来他们可能没有足够的动力。如果只有一家公司，那么人们总是会担心，哦，这只是他们的公司，这一家公司的东西吗？就像，哦，这只是Google的语言或Facebook的语言？
And you can't really become a successful language until you grow beyond that. You know, for Rust, it was originally like this Mozilla thing, and it took a few years to grow beyond that. But do you think of Rust as Mozilla's language now? Yeah, not really, no. Yeah. In fact, when I talk about Rust, when we talk about Rust, I don't even think it's come up that Rust was developed at Mozilla Research. I bet if you searched through every previous episode of this podcast, I don't even think we've mentioned it that that rust started at mozilla it might have been it might have been brought up on the episodes where we interviewed jane
你不能真正成为一种成功的语言，直到你超越了这一点。你知道，对于Rust，它最初就像是Mozilla的东西，花了几年时间才超越了这一点。但你现在认为Rust是Mozilla的语言吗？是的，不完全是，没有。是的。事实上，当我谈论Rust时，当我们谈论Rust时，我甚至不认为Rust是在Mozilla Research开发的这一点被提到了。我敢打赌，如果你搜索这个播客的每一集，我甚至不认为我们提到过Rust起源于Mozilla。它可能是在我们采访Jane的剧集中被提到了
oh yeah that may have come up there um but but the fact that i can't like that neither of us can remember whether we talked about its origins that that speaks well for it you know rust is used by a variety of companies now, and it's got a foundation. And it's not just, you know, it's not just, you know, one company's thing. And a language to be truly successful has to grow beyond becoming one company's thing. I mean, unless you're Java and Oracle, in which case, you know, you can just... It'd be interesting to get, because we've got plans not to spoil our... Although, you know, spoil is generous,
哦，是的，那可能在那里提到了，嗯，但事实上我不能，我们俩都不记得我们是否谈论过它的起源，这说明它很好，你知道，Rust现在被各种公司使用，它有一个基金会。它不仅仅是，你知道，它不仅仅是，你知道，一家公司的东西。一种语言要真正成功，必须成长到超越成为一家公司的东西。我的意思是，除非你是Java和Oracle，在这种情况下，你知道，你可以只是……如果能得到，那会很有趣，因为我们有计划不剧透我们的……虽然，你知道，剧透是慷慨的，
because we've had these people on our list for like a year plus now. We plan to get, you know, Andrew Kelly of Zig on, some Russ folks on. It might be interesting to get some Go folks on. I mean, even Rob rob pike because go is a fascinating language in that yes it was championed by google but it's definitely grown to a point where like it's not identified as like the google language anymore like that's what i i do still kind of think of it as the google language um i mean it's the origin. The origins were in Google. But like it's a language that just entered the top 10 on some programming language rankings. And it's like ranks above Rust.
因为我们名单上的人已经有一年多了。我们计划邀请，你知道，Zig的Andrew Kelly，一些Rust的人。邀请一些Go的人可能会很有趣。我的意思是，甚至Rob Pike，因为Go是一种迷人的语言，是的，它是由Google拥护的，但它绝对成长到了一个地步，就像它不再被标识为Google语言了，就像那是，我确实仍然有点认为它是Google语言，嗯，我的意思是它是起源。起源是在Google。但就像它是一种刚刚进入某些编程语言排名前10的语言。而且它排名高于Rust。
But you don't hear nearly as much buzz or hype about Go than you do, or at least I don't, compared to Rust. And yeah, I find that curious. And also it's a language that is like a programming language enthusiast. Like no PL theory people or PL, you know, that kind of space academics. They're not really big fans of it because it didn't do anything really interesting or exciting other than maybe like their concurrency model. And everything else was either like already done before not novel or like pretty boring and the fact that they didn't have generics until like 1.18 you know a lot of pl enthusiasts were just like well the language is done like it like i'm not going to use it if it doesn't have that
但你听到的关于Go的嗡嗡声或炒作远没有你听到的那么多，或者至少我没有，与Rust相比。是的，我发现这很奇怪。而且它也是一种像编程语言爱好者那样的语言。像没有PL理论的人或PL，你知道，那种领域的学者。他们并不是它的忠实粉丝，因为它没有做任何真正有趣或令人兴奋的事情，除了可能像他们的并发模型。而其他一切要么是以前做过的，不是新颖的，要么是相当无聊的，而且事实上直到1.18左右他们才有了泛型，你知道，很多PL爱好者只是说，好吧，语言完成了，就像，如果它没有那个，我就不会使用它
anyways it's just interesting that like a language that compared to many other languages is kind of boring and simple has done even better than like a language like rust it would be interesting it would be interesting to talk about and to look at go because uh you know our colleague andre he likes to say that you know a language has to be 10x better than the competition in some way shape or form to to succeed and so there must be some 10x aspect to go that's led to success i feel like maybe it's like a bunch of like two to five x improvements on a bunch of small things which like totals because like it's compiled times are incredibly fast it produces like a single executable like you don't have to link stuff
无论如何，有趣的是，一种与许多其他语言相比有点无聊和简单的语言，甚至比像Rust这样的语言做得更好。谈论并看看Go会很有趣，因为嗯，你知道，我们的同事Andre，他喜欢说，你知道，一种语言必须在某种程度上比竞争对手好10倍才能成功，所以Go一定有一些10倍的方面导致了成功。我觉得也许它就像一堆两到五倍的改进，在很多小事情上，这加起来，因为它的编译时间非常快，它产生一个单一的可执行文件，就像你不需要链接东西
it's like it's just much simpler all the code looks the same anyways we'll get a go expert on we're running short on time we got less than 10 minutes left uh any other 2023 i think it's got to have some i don't think that a bunch of two x's to five x's are um uh is equal to a 10x and even one dimension so i just linked you um uh an interesting thing about 2023 which is it just came out the jet brains annual c++ ecosystem survey, which I consider the best survey of the C++ ecosystem and community. And I don't know, maybe we can look at it and see if there are some interesting trends going on. I read it. It was kind of boring.
它就像它简单得多，所有的代码看起来都一样。无论如何，我们会请一位Go专家，我们时间不多了，我们剩下不到10分钟，嗯，还有其他2023年，我认为它必须有一些，我不认为一堆两倍到五倍等于10倍，甚至在一个维度上，所以我刚链接给你，嗯，关于2023年的一件有趣的事情，就是它刚出来，JetBrains年度C++生态系统调查，我认为这是对C++生态系统和社区最好的调查。我不知道，也许我们可以看看它，看看是否有任何有趣的趋势。我读了。它有点无聊。
Thanks, buddy. You know, I was one of the three people that they asked for feedback on it. I mean, like, what is there to say? People are moving to more recent standards. Python's the next most popular language that C devs know. VS Code is the most popular after that. It's shocking to see a drop in the survey numbers of CMake,
谢谢，伙计。你知道，我是他们要求反馈的三个人之一。我的意思是，有什么可说的？人们正在转向更新的标准。Python是C开发者知道的第二大流行语言。VS Code是之后最流行的。看到CMake的调查数字下降令人震惊，
although I suggest that means that there's just a margin of error in that CMake has saturated at about 50% market share. Yeah. It's hard to look into these numbers, you know. Anything you want to remark on it? Well, if I remember my... Let me see if I can remember my remarks
尽管我建议这意味着CMake在约50%的市场份额上已经饱和，只是存在误差范围。是的。很难深入研究这些数字，你知道。你有什么想评论的吗？嗯，如果我记得我的……让我看看我是否能记得我的评论
that I originally sent to them. So I mentioned that there's... We saw a large jump in adoption of C++20, which isn't shocking because it usually takes two to three years for implementations to really pick up the latest
我最初发给他们的。所以我提到有……我们看到C++20的采用率有很大跳跃，这并不令人震惊，因为实现真正采用最新标准通常需要两到三年。
standard. And I think this is not just a C++ thing. I think it's true that for almost anything it takes a while for adoption to really pick up. Once you put out a new thing, it takes a while for adoption to really pick up. You know, once you put out a new thing, it takes a while for it to saturate in the ecosystem. But, you know, C++20 usage going from 23% to 29%, that's a pretty big jump, especially relative to the other dialects.
我认为这不仅仅是C++的事情。我认为对于几乎任何事情，采用率真正上升都需要一段时间。一旦你推出一个新东西，采用率真正上升需要一段时间。你知道，一旦你推出一个新东西，它在生态系统中饱和需要一段时间。但是，你知道，C++20的使用率从23%上升到29%，这是一个相当大的跳跃，特别是相对于其他方言。
I was surprised to see that almost 50% of people plan to use modules in the next 12 months, which is interesting because that's one feature where we haven't seen a ton of adoption yet. But just recently, CMake launched their support for C++ modules in a non-experimental way. It had been experimental for a while, but now it's fully baked. And so maybe we will see a lot of adoption of modules in the next year. And so maybe we will see a lot of adoption of modules in the next year. In particular, we may see a lot of adoption of using the standard library module. Even if you're not making your own library and your own code into modules, you might just use the module from your standard library, the std module, which can give you some significant uh compilation uh time wins um
我很惊讶地看到几乎50%的人计划在未来12个月内使用模块，这很有趣，因为这是一个我们还没有看到大量采用的功能。但就在最近，CMake以非实验性的方式推出了对C++模块的支持。它已经实验了一段时间，但现在已经完全成熟了。所以也许我们会在明年看到模块的大量采用。特别是，我们可能会看到使用标准库模块的大量采用。即使你没有把自己制作成模块的库和代码，你可能只是使用标准库中的模块，std模块，这可以给你带来一些显著的编译时间优势，嗯
so i i think that that's the the the the first way that we'll see people using modules is not providing their own modules but just using the std module yeah i've tried every four months for like the last couple years because i've seen talks and i've seen demos and i've seen articles about how it's usable and i've even seen like someone with a microsoft visual studio use import stud and it just never works like uh they've always you gotta always check a bunch of boxes and experimental blah blah and the thing is is i think a lot of these they ship with some you know starter experience for modules but like standardization of these standard headers or whatever, that's a C++23 feature, which as far as I know,
所以我认为这是我们将看到人们使用模块的第一种方式，不是提供他们自己的模块，而是只是使用std模块。是的，过去几年我每四个月尝试一次，因为我看到了演讲，看到了演示，看到了关于它如何可用的文章，我甚至看到有人用Microsoft Visual Studio使用import std，但它从来没用过，就像嗯，你总是得检查一堆框和实验性的等等，问题是，我认为很多这些，它们带着一些模块的入门体验发布，但像这些标准头文件或什么的标准化，那是C++23的功能，据我所知，
no library has done the work for yet. Anyways, hopefully people can start to use modules. And I got two or three more interesting things here. So one, you know, survey results indicate people still not using package managers. Very low adoption, only like 11% adoption of VC package, which is the most successful one. And the other ones account for like maybe 12% combined, maybe a little bit more than that, but only like 25% of people are using some form of package manager. And that doesn't necessarily surprise me,
还没有库为此做过工作。无论如何，希望人们能开始使用模块。我这里还有两三件有趣的事情。所以第一，你知道，调查结果显示人们仍然不使用包管理器。采用率非常低，只有约11%的VC package采用率，这是最成功的一个。其他的加起来可能总共约12%，可能比那多一点，但只有约25%的人在使用某种形式的包管理器。这并不一定让我感到惊讶，
but I wonder whether we'll start to see more and more adoption and more centralization around one of them. Like in particular, VC package seems to be the leader. And in terms of IDEs, this is the first year that the survey where Visual Studio has been tied with another IDE for the top spot. Usually Visual Studio shows up as the most popular IDE, but this year it's tied with the JetBrains CLion IDE, which is pretty interesting. Because you look at back when CLion came out in the market market and really there was only just one IDE, Visual Studio,
但我不知道我们是否会开始看到越来越多的采用和围绕其中一个的集中化。比如特别是，VC package似乎是领导者。在IDE方面，这是调查中Visual Studio与另一个IDE并列第一的第一年。通常Visual Studio显示为最流行的IDE，但今年它与JetBrains CLion IDE并列，这非常有趣。因为你看看CLion刚进入市场时，市场上真的只有一个IDE，Visual Studio，
and then I guess if you were on Mac, there was Xcode. But now we're seeing a lot more diversity in developer environments for C++. I think that's pretty much it from the survey. But I do think there's some interesting insights to be gleaned from it. Yeah? Link will be in the show notes if you want to read it yourself. All right. We've got
然后我想如果你在Mac上，有Xcode。但现在我们看到C++的开发环境多样性多了很多。我想调查中基本上就是这些了。但我确实认为从中可以得出一些有趣的见解。是吗？如果你想自己阅读，链接将在节目说明中。好了。我们剩下
three minutes left, four minutes left. Predictions for 2024. Yeah. So I, well, not predictions. I got to do my recap of 2023. I mean, technically you already heard it last time we recorded, but then we lost it. Anyways, I'll rattle through them quickly. I'm not even sure if this is the right order because I had it down before and then deleted it. We'll come in with number five, which was hanging out with Sean Parent at C++ on C back at the tail end of June. That turned into three different episodes. It was an absolute blast. When Sean was on, we made a reference to it. Hopefully, we'll get to do something like that similar
三分钟，四分钟。2024年预测。是的。所以，嗯，不是预测。我得做我的2023年回顾。我的意思是，技术上你上次录制时已经听过了，但后来我们丢失了。无论如何，我会快速说出来。我甚至不确定这是否是正确的顺序，因为我之前写下来了，然后删除了。我们从第五名开始，那是六月底在C++ on C与Sean Parent在一起。那变成了三集不同的节目。那绝对是一次爆炸。当Sean在的时候，我们提到了它。希望我们能在2024年的不同聚会或会议上做类似的事情
at a different meetup or conference in 2024. Number four is the two top conferences, in my opinion, for the year were KXCon, which is the conference put on by First Derivatives that focuses around the Q language, and Lambda Days, the functional programming plus plus conference that takes place in Krakow, Poland. Hope to go back to both of these conferences in 2024, but time will tell if that works out with my schedule. Number three, similar to what Bryce said, Slovenia 2023 trip. I still have fond memories thinking about wandering through the streets of Venice, recording podcasts, getting donuts, eating snacks. Fantastic. Number two was not tech related. It was all the running. Check out the running podcast, link in the show notes. We're not going to say more about it here.
第四名是两场顶级会议，在我看来，今年是KXCon，这是First Derivatives举办的专注于Q语言的会议，以及Lambda Days，在波兰克拉科夫举行的函数式编程加加会议。希望在2024年能回到这两场会议，但时间会证明这是否符合我的日程安排。第三名，类似于Bryce说的，2023年斯洛文尼亚之旅。我仍然有美好的回忆，想到在威尼斯的街道上漫步，录制播客，买甜甜圈，吃零食。太棒了。第二名与技术无关。全是跑步。查看跑步播客，链接在节目说明中。我们在这里不再多说了。
And number one is to be announced at a later date in 2024. All right. Anything else? Or we got like one minute left. 2024 predictions, Bryce, go. 2024 predictions. Didn't we already do these a little bit? Well, okay.
第一名将在2024年晚些时候宣布。好了。还有别的吗？或者我们剩下大约一分钟。2024年预测，Bryce，开始。2024年预测。我们不是已经做过一点了吗？好吧，好的。
So one prediction. I don't think that there will be as much exciting large language model news this year as there was last year. Because last year was like the big hype curve, and now we've got the slow road to adoption. I think that there will be breakthroughs and developments, but I don't think that there will be quite as much excitement as there has been. I think that we're on like a five to 10 year road of productization. I think that reflection will probably make significant progress in C++. I'm hoping to get more involved in the Rust world this year. I may try to go to RustConf and doing some other compiler things
所以一个预测。我不认为今年会有像去年那样令人兴奋的大型语言模型新闻。因为去年就像巨大的炒作曲线，现在我们有了缓慢的采用之路。我认为会有突破和发展，但我不认为会有像过去那样多的兴奋。我认为我们正处于5到10年的产品化道路上。我认为反射可能会在C++中取得重大进展。我希望今年能更多地参与Rust世界。我可能会尝试去RustConf并做一些其他编译器方面的事情
that are pretty exciting that I don't think I can share many more details about other than that they're exciting. I'm going to Ireland with my mother for right before ECCU in a couple months so we're excited about that. If you live, if you happen to live anywhere between Dublin and Dingle
非常令人兴奋，除了它们令人兴奋之外，我不认为我能分享更多细节。几个月后，在ECCU之前，我要和我的母亲去爱尔兰，所以我们对此很兴奋。如果你住，如果你碰巧住在都柏林和丁格尔之间的任何地方
which is as far as I can tell on the westernmost side of Ireland and you want, which is, as far as I can tell, on the westernmost side of Ireland. And you want to hang out. My mom and I are going to be driving from Dingle back to Dublin because we have a friend who lives in Dingle. And the most convenient way to get from there to our flight is to drive. So we're going to have a little bit of an Irish road trip. So if anybody wants to hang out meet my mother let me know
据我所知，那是爱尔兰的最西端。你想去那里逛逛。我和我妈妈将从丁格尔开车回都柏林，因为我们有个朋友住在丁格尔。从那里去赶飞机的最方便方式就是开车。所以我们要进行一次小型的爱尔兰公路旅行。如果有人想出来聚聚、见见我母亲，请告诉我。
any other conferences you just you just alluded to the fact that you're going to accu any other conferences that you're planning at the moment or tbd yeah it's a minute to cpp north but they were they didn't accept me last year so who knows knows? I may not be good enough for them. I may go to C++ now. Cpp on C it may go to. The dates are a little tricky for me. Let's see other conferences. I'm actually, I'm still in the process of putting together.
还有其他会议吗？你刚才提到你要去ACCU，目前还有其他计划中的会议吗，还是待定？是的，离CPP North还有一段时间，但他们去年没录用我，所以谁知道呢？也许我还没达到他们的要求。我可能会去C++ Now。Cpp on Sea我也可能会去。日期对我来说有点难安排。看看其他会议。实际上，我还在整理中。
I'll probably be at CodeDive and I'll be at Core C++ and probably a couple other ones thrown in there. Awesome. I think, yeah, of the ones that you said, I've submitted to CPP North. Yeah. Announcement, if you didn't know. CPP North's call for proposals is open until, I think, mid-February. What are the other ones I've submitted to?
我可能会去CodeDive，也会去Core C++，可能还会参加其他几个会议。太棒了。我想，在你说的那些会议中，我已经向CPP North提交了申请。是的，顺便宣布一下，如果你还不知道的话，CPP North的提案征集截止日期大概在二月中旬。我还向哪些会议提交了申请？
But nobody submit because I want my talk to be accepted. Definitely submit. If Bryce can't, you know, get his talk accepted. That just gives us fodder for the podcast. Yeah. And what are the other ones? I submitted to Lambda Days, KXCons, Details isn't out yet, PLDI, which is going to be in Copenhagen. If there is going to be an array workshop, I would like to submit a paper there. But they have not posted on the PLDI website whether or not that's going to happen or not yet. That's in June. And I think, oh yeah, PyCon I submitted a talk to. And also,
但你们别提交，因为我想让我的演讲被录用。一定要提交。如果Bryce的演讲没被录用，那正好给我们播客提供素材。是的。还有哪些会议？我向Lambda Days、KXCons提交了申请，细节还没出来；还有PLDI，将在哥本哈根举行。如果那里有数组研讨会，我想提交一篇论文。但他们还没在PLDI网站上发布是否会举办。那是在六月。我想，哦对了，我还向PyCon提交了一个演讲。还有，
I submitted my talk to an NDC conference. So yeah, I don't think I'll get accepted to all of them, but I'll definitely be. Once we're accepted, if we're accepted, we will let the listeners know. And a promise to close out episode 165, recap of 2023, a look ahead to 2024. We will have merch. Well, not like purchasable merch. Maybe we will. But we will definitely have stickers. For those of you that have come up and said hi and said kind things about the podcast at conferences in 2023, we didn't have stickers.
我向NDC会议提交了我的演讲。所以，我不认为我会被所有会议录用，但我肯定会参加。一旦我们被录用，如果被录用的话，我们会通知听众。承诺结束第165期节目，回顾2023，展望2024。我们将会有周边商品。嗯，不是那种可以购买的周边。也许会有。但我们肯定会有贴纸。对于那些在2023年会议上走过来打招呼并对我们的播客表示赞赏的朋友，我们当时没有贴纸。
This year, it's an ADSP promise. We're going to have ADSP stickers. So be sure to ask if you bump into us at one of the conferences and you'd like one. Any other closing thoughts? So wait, so wait. Now I have to figure out how to make room in my standard luggage for stickers?
今年，这是ADSP的承诺。我们会有ADSP贴纸。所以如果你在会议上遇到我们并想要一张，一定要问我们要。还有其他结束语吗？等等，等等。现在我得想办法在我的标准行李里为贴纸腾出空间？
All right, I'm going to rephrase what I just said. I, Connor Hoekstra, co-host of ADSP, will have ADSP stickers. I will have ADSP stickers as well. If you would like one, come up to me. Bryce may or may not. It is unclear depending on how packed his luggages are. All right, folks. Episode 166, are we going to have a guest?
好吧，我重新说一遍。我，ADSP的联合主持人Connor Hoekstra，会有ADSP贴纸。我也会有ADSP贴纸。如果你想要一张，就过来找我。Bryce可能会有，也可能没有。这取决于他的行李塞得有多满，目前还不清楚。好了，各位。第166期节目，我们会邀请嘉宾吗？
Maybe, maybe not. We'll figure that out in between now and the next time when we record. Be sure to check these show notes either in your podcast app or at adsptopodcast.com for links to anything we mentioned in the episode, as well as a link to the GitHub discussion where you can leave thoughts, comments, and questions. Thanks for listening. We hope you enjoyed and have a great day. Low quality, high high quantity that is the
也许会，也许不会。我们会在现在到下次录制之间决定。请务必查看播客应用或adsptopodcast.com上的节目说明，获取我们在节目中提到的任何内容的链接，以及GitHub讨论链接，你可以在那里留下想法、评论和问题。感谢收听。希望你喜欢，祝你有愉快的一天。低质量，高数量，这就是
tagline of our podcast it's not the tagline our tagline is chaos with sprinkles of information There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我们播客的标语。那不是标语，我们的标语是“混乱中撒点信息”。本期节目还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。